ryan married beautiful blake sexiest man
in the world all those things
and yes she is the sexiest man yeah yeah
he's doing well there
that's a good shot right there look at
you look at you
beautiful and happy yeah so annoying
yeah
no but to cheer us up when you started
kind of being interested in girls
you weren't as that cool or smooth with
it
no no no not at all i don't believe it
no no i really
i went through puberty at like 27. this
was a freak thing
yeah it was not good yeah who was the
girl who was the girl in school the
first the first girl the first well
i was obsessed with this this girl uh uh
fiona gorczynski
who uh
she said and she used to actually she
used to take the bus the the the
opposite way of my actual home
and i would get on the bus just to sit
next to her wow for
45 minutes the wrong way oh there's
something wonderful about there was
something
when you're young it's so cute when
you're older it's just stalking
you're like on some kind of watch list
yeah but but i remember when i was i
couldn't have been more than i don't
know 11 years old and i and i
i was just about to get off the bus
because enough is enough i'm about to
enter like seattle or something so
i'm starting to get off the bus and i
decided to like kind of hit her with
like this cool look or something like
this like one of these like real
sort of don johnson miami can you feel
it
right
i do this i do this move as i'm getting
down off the bus
and i sort of delay a little too long
and the bus doors close on my backpack
with my backpack and the bus just starts
to leak
like banging on the side of the bus the
bus driver finally stops opens the door
let's releases my
you know idiot bag backpack and i i
could never look at her again
yeah that was terrible yeah she's
looking at you now
can you imagine she's like he's the guy
with the backpack
he's the idiot with the ren and stimpy
backpack
samuel has very kindly taken
photographic evidence
uh you've taken some selfies where is
this in blackpool
and is that you yeah that's me
that is you okay that's my signature
actually i'm a little high in the
picture i'm usually in the corner
that's from my room that's a lovely bit
of blackpool yeah
that's the that's the street that runs
along the side of my room
okay and then we've got the view for the
blackpool tower yes
you look super imposed in this picture
it looks like you're not really there
but i got these dope ass glasses on so
you know it's really good yeah
and then then this is i think again you
just about make
it into this selfie you've taken a
picture of yourself outside fleetwood
uh there's the ear but the sign was
really good
this i don't believe this fleetwood
where breastfeeding is always welcome
what happened in fleetwood that's a real
sign
yes that's the one that's the welcome to
fleetwood sign
what age do you have to be to breastfeed
in fleetwood it's always
stop the car now you have to take a
photo of this
and then we went into town to just see
how many bad breaths were hanging out
just you know
but i don't something must have happened
in fleetwood that that sign is there
i have no idea but we must google it we
should in fact we should have
maybe yeah yeah we should have it's
absolutely real i know i believe you i
believe you but
in in zorro you you know lots of people
do sword fights and it's called
choreographers a lot of people do
survive well you know what i mean did
you train with the spanish olympic team
i did i did for four months i trained
with the spanish olympics it's true
[Music]
make it do things let me do it did you
see that let me see
what
you wouldn't kill it okay
um okay uh there are i think
uh one two three four five seven
positions okay okay
so five first of all you put this hang
on like this
[Music]
comfortable and relaxed okay
and now this is the first position i
know oh generally it wouldn't be awful
if i killed antonio banderas
okay so here we go yeah first position
yeah that's good first
and then that's not that bad second
first and second
third and fourth
i've cut my own leg but there you go six
and then what fancy one in case somebody
attacked you in the back like this oh
okay so that's you're so good i thought
so i thought
you can try this this is just fine
[Applause]
yes fancy
oh yes because you could have been a
professional soccer player
uh i could have but i broke my left foot
when i was
15 years old
you used to be weren't you good enough
to be an olympic gymnast that's true
was it a
and the plane hadn't yet taken off and
the um
the the woman who had just gotten
married
uh just became violently and horribly
ill on the plane i mean
it was not like a pretty little like
sick bag
kind of thing it was just like i'm going
to paint with my organs
like it was just crazy and people were
freaking out all over the plane and
there so they brought a stretcher down
and they put her on the stretcher and
they're wheeling her away and like
the the uh her her new husband is just
kind of cruising along with the thing
and he sees me and he's like
deadpool no way high five and i
i'm like i don't what do you like what
has she got like what's happening
you know like you know like he's like
let's touch eyeballs
no no and by the way your wife is like
half dead
helper man so it's just a very surreal
moment i'm
i'm sure they're fine i'm sure they're
on their second uh anniversary now
just kicking it somewhere the other day
i was in berlin um
sunday monday tuesday i went to a
restaurant sunday night
and when i walked in somebody had
another table went oh my god it's denzel
i just kind of looked at the corner of
my eye and i moved on we got to our
table the guy behind us turned around
morgan freeman
no i'm not morgan freeman yeah yeah come
on you're morgan freeman
oh i guarantee you i'm not morgan
freeman oh man took my phone out google
morgan freeman put his picture up
and did that and the guy was like yeah
[Applause]
because salma you i mean you spoke
english when you came to america
i spoke shopping english
small mediums
wasn't there a thing when you got a
review of desperado and you thought it
was a bad review
do you remember oh yes because they said
bomb
salman hadjik bombshell and i said oh my
god they are saying that i
bombed the movie that i died
and then you do these movies but then
afterwards you've got to presumably do
things like this you've got to do
press not speaking very good english
that was
that was bad i made huge mistakes there
what was it a journalist who asked you
what was your
favorite american food yeah and i
answered him francis ford coppola
do you see
you're just projecting
[Applause]
tell me you're right i really like him
i know that but salma some of you broke
uh a billion hearts when you said
i do to miss your pinot pinot yes
so it's you uh bishopino
[Music]
you've got your daughter but is it
you're the only one in the house who
doesn't speak french
yeah i speak very very bad french
very very bad but isn't that your own
fault you had the opportunity
i did i did my parents sent me
a long time to to learn french when i
was really young
and it sounded like a good idea but then
when i got to paris and they told me i
had to go to las vegas
eight hours straight private lessons in
french
at 16 17. what a terrible opportunity
imagine for the summer
i'm sorry when you're 17. i'm a talent
in a classroom with a teacher so
i lied i told my parents that my teacher
died
anyway i don't trust you
dangerous woman well right now i'll tell
you i regret it i wish i hadn't killed
that teacher because
yes because just your husband and
daughter do they plot against you
i understand it now oh okay yeah those
days are gone
you should have pretended that you still
didn't understand it i did for a while
with some of the people too ooh did you
find that good dirt
oh yeah okay it was good to be a spy for
five minutes now
i don't want to be indelicate but samuel
apparently you have recently lost your
title
as the highest grossing actor of all
time yeah
i've been displaced by harrison ford
again i displaced him he displaced me
but hey it's only 70 mil
yeah it's like a weekend i got them
covered in july
he's lucky i'm not in captain america
three now
have you seen the new star wars yeah
okay all right moving on it would have
been better with you in it yeah
that's really yeah that's that's that's
the bottom line or more popular anyway
it couldn't be more popular yes it could
i haven't seen it and i would have
watched it a few reasons i see right
there
right there yeah but you do watch all
your films this is right yes i do
like more religiously i do
i watch them at home i i go to the
theater i know
when i have a movie that's opening i
know it's gonna make
at least a thousand dollars that weekend
because i buy a thousand dollars worth
of tickets
and i give them to the church or i give
them to somebody and their kids go
but i i go in the movie after the
movie's been opened for a moment
you know to see what normal people are
saying or doing while they're watching
the film to see how they react to it
when you go to a premiere i mean
everybody's had a kiss your ass you know
come on yeah
they're gonna love the movie oh my god
you are amazing you know and then you go
with some regular people they go out of
movies this
movie sucked yeah but that's sam jackson
was the [__] he's always the [__]
yeah i go i like it if i'm sitting at
home
and if i'm you know if i'm channel
surfing there's nothing else on
i i go into the search engine and go
samuel jackson boom
you know you all have to do accents but
ryan we don't think of canadians as
having
accents and yet you do you've lost your
accent you would say
yeah i sort of trained myself out of it
but you know i go back home and it it
pops up again it's
uh that's all ottawa i hear that's all
ottawa oh yeah
stay about uh it's a well in canada it's
a boat
that's what i'm saying say it the way
you say what do you talk about what are
you talking about
but it's all my everything is i it's a
bad word but i'm sorry so
you handle everything without [__] buddy
and is it something about the canadian
accent that makes you a really bad liar
um yeah well yeah we're not we're not
good at it lying or fighting
really i mean that's it's all slappy
it's not very sexy
oh yeah yeah i was i i my wife is a
foodie she
she loves these uh apple pies that they
make at this at this place in vancouver
where i grew up so we grabbed a bunch of
them and
headed we were driving back down to the
states and we were across the board
you're not allowed to cross the border
with like
that's illegal right yeah and this guy
knew something was going on and now we
get up to the border crossing high
smugglers yeah pie smokers
most like hollywood actress they have
like a kilo of cocaine in this
difference
you know uh so yeah
but he knew some was going on right
he says my voice always gets really high
when i'm when i'm like
lying he was like he got anything any
sort of fruit any vegetables anything
like that i was like no
it's a vegetable
and he's basically he ages had me on the
hook and he looks at me and goes
hey i remember that you know the movie
you did that movie just friends and i
was like yeah yeah yeah he was like you
know that song at the end of it where
you sing this
i swear by all for one and i was like
yeah he was like yeah
go ahead
basically you're saying dance monkey
i bet you dance i dance
ryan the thing about you growing up i
love the the you told stories about
growing up because your dad
it was like he was training you for
paparazzi he was very snap happy
yeah he was i was actually the saddest
moment in our childhood
and these are uptown problems was when
they switched from
film to digital because to my father
that was just like
every day was the lottery i mean it was
amazing because you could just take
pictures and pictures and pictures
thousands of them it could be
like thousands of pictures of just a
meatloaf that's blurry
and what he would do is at the end of
the night he would email everyone in the
family
all the all the photographs as well yeah
but the the thing is this is back when
like
the internet was made of a fax machine
of wood like
and then you would download all of these
things and like you like it was so much
material to download you'd feel like the
lights dim in your home like
this must be costing a fortune and i got
i used to say them i was like
can you stop you don't need to send
every phone like we don't need to see
the blurry photo of the ceiling you took
when you like just edit yourself
never did so after a while and i i i
mean i deeply regret this
now as an adult male i have deep regrets
what i did but i would take the camera
sometimes in the middle of dinner and
i'd just go in the bathroom and i just
i just just grab a quick shot of my
penis
and then he'd email it to everybody nana
and kathy uncle tim
uh gramps got a few of those
they think it was his though um no i
well that was his concern which is what
actually in a weird way made the whole
thing work for me so
after that he became a strict editor so
you'd get just two
lovely family photos at the end of an
evening not sixty thousand shots of a
of a you know mashed potato yeah not
a penis out of penis yeah i thought you
were saying it looked like a mashed
potato and i was like
this is what i was just thinking as i
was listening to that story which by the
way i didn't hear a word of
okay just now because like did you did
you grow up with a kid like in
elementary school or whatever and you
were always kind of amazed by the kid it
was like the kid over there doing the
jokes and the talking and all that kind
of kind of
and then the rest of the class kind of
was in awe
every time that i'm with him it's like
somebody spiked my water with lsd
and i'm just sitting there in awe
this is lovely no but it's not it's not
it's meant to be a compliment i'm sober
i'm not supposed to have lsd
no yeah this is no i'm literally i found
myself halfway through the story going
like this
you just you're high on ryan i heard
something about mashed potatoes of facts
with wood and your dad
yeah that's actually the name of my
memoir
way to blow it thank you spoiler alert
yeah
and theater actors are always
complaining about things like you know
mobile phones going off in the audience
when you're on stage
but that can happen in on film sets as
well
i turn to you yeah oh yeah that's
happened to me yes that's a terrible
feeling i did a movie with a
a guy who's a very serious actor uh
named denzel washington
and um doesn't really like to rehearse a
lot just goes in there and
just nails it but you just get like one
or two takes that's it
and uh uh this is a scene a movie called
safe house and it's toward the end of
the film and his character's dying on
the ground it's
very emotional he's crying and all this
stuff in my character goes and sort of
grabs him and it's the one moment our
characters kind of
connect for the first time in the movie
and i'm i'm holding him i know you get
one take of this he's going to give you
everything and then we're done
and i'm sitting there and i'm holding
him and suddenly i hear
come fly with me let's fly away
and ever i could feel everyone panicking
around i could
hear the first ad going whose phone is
that and i hear one of the stunt guys
whose phone is that and denzel so far
hasn't really noticed i don't think he's
still kind of crying he's still kind of
in
all this stuff they finally called
they're still playing right it's frank
sinatra's coming out of my ass
the phone is untucked underneath them i
guess it hit that like siri button or
something
and heard play come fly with me and uh
so i'm having just a complete nervous
breakdown i don't know what to do like
because denzel washington is very
intimidating i'm thinking like
he's just going to turn me into a liquid
so like what do i say you know and they
call
cut and and the the first day developed
yes who that [__] phone is that
denzel goes whose [__] phone was that
and i stand up and i look at all the
stunt guys and i go
who the [__] phone was that
slowly kind of back out of the room the
first lady is still looking around for
the guy did i look at him
thankfully denzel gave us another take
and he didn't hit me or anything he was
very small
he was very sweet about it oh yeah i
told him a year later by the way
that was me well we were talking with uh
antonio and salma about
you know their difficulties with english
when they got to america sure but
in this tour this is good um you do a
kind of master class in accents well i
was trying to get better i've been doing
like i've been a stand-up comedian for
like 10 years and i was trying to get
better at it
i thought what can i get better at an
accents so i've gone away discover the
secret of doing like good regional
accents is you need a key phrase
to get you started if you're doing the
accent and once you get that key phrase
in your head
then you get started i i can teach you
like smackdown
i can't do yours i can do ones from
around britain i could do
british people and you know meryl streep
gets them all now
and you know you could be in desperate
scouse wives
so like the scout saxon so if you want
to talk like someone from liverpool you
say this this phrase you say
autumn chicken and a can of coke
you got to try okay you too i want some
chicken and i cannot cook
i want some chicken and i want a horse
[Applause]
you sounded like you were trying to be a
ventriloquist there
because then once you say it then you
can say something properly authentically
scouts
like you said autumn chicken i'm going
on the rob
i've got to get a prezi it's me gran's
birthday
he's
[Applause]
liverpool is the only town in great
britain where jd sports has an evening
wear department
i'll teach you another accent from the
uk
roller coaster pooper scooper kawasaki
four
unrelated words but if you want to do
the geordie accent
how people talk from newcastle those
words
rula costa cumpass okay
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
you